good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast happy Tuesday
hope everyone's having a great day thus
far welcome back to the toast hey Jax
how you doing I'm darn good since we've
been welcomed back to now twice yeah and
it was important to welcome people to be
and to be a welcoming person to double
the welcome double the fun
you just said a mouthful there sister
anyways I feel sufficiently welcomed
back to the toast I'm glad that this is
a welcoming environment for everyone
today uh thank you for that attorney
it's a pleasure
um before we Dive In
let's talk really quickly just send some
love to our Nashville toasters yesterday
was such a terrible day
um I know everyone all over Nashville is
just heartbroken and so we just wanted
to take a moment and acknowledge what
happened at you know that school with
those beautiful kids who are just it's
just a it's a horrible
it's it was a terrible day yeah I
have so many words it's not the forum
for all of them but
I just
am heartbroken and this morning choosing
stories it's like it's what's the point
yeah what's the point
um there's also like more news like
coming out there's footage now of oh no
the
girl breaking in and
um roaming the halls and everything and
it's just horrible
and I know we have a lot of toasters
like from that area and just Nashville
in general so we just wanted to send
love today we're gonna you know do our
best what we always do which is just to
bring love and light
and moronic you know mindless news just
to get your mind off of things for a
while yeah that's what we do and we
shall do such a thing we will he's like
today it's certainly hard yeah so we'll
give it our best shot yeah so tell me
what's going on with you how are you Jax
how's World he's good I am good not much
is new I know I was really busy
yesterday
um so I know you were probably looking
for me
um but I wasn't by my phone I just could
feel like turdy was needing me Jackie
was like with a friend for an hour and
she called me she's like yeah I was I
was like out of commission I'm like I
didn't even call you like what I didn't
even know you were gone I know but I
just felt like I wasn't there for you in
that hour because I wasn't you weren't I
wasn't good thing I wasn't needed by you
but
um I just I had to let you know like I'm
here now I just and I do want to let you
know like you had a friend over and we
were fine we'll be okay
we'll be okay I know you're probably
just feeling like a little you know
maybe left out because Olivia's in town
Olivia's in New York we had dinner
yesterday like you know everyone was
together and like you weren't so I
understand you like this is like a cry
for health essentially well yes you
could see it that way but you could also
see it the way of like the party that I
was at last night which was the kids
party like you were at the adult section
yeah I was at the kids party and
I don't know
which one I don't know which one either
so I think we all had a good fun night I
think we all had a good fun night too
you know today's a big day I have my
second physical therapy appointment I
will try to keep my pants on this time
good luck I know like you know what I
feel more confident going in knowing
I've been through it once and I know
exactly what garments need to be taken
off yeah and I tried to dress like in
you know like and I'll just wear like
leggings and a bra like I I'm feeling
good I'm feeling confident maybe even a
sports bra
no he has to unclip my bra which really
was like a very like you know personal I
was like oh I get on a clip and he's
like no I got it like he does this every
day but I was like wow this man is
taking my bra off
whoa you didn't tell us about that
there's so many elements of physical
therapy that are so deeply personal
Physical Therapy more personal than
comedy more personal than food I'm sorry
but thankful there sister that's really
crazy that he unclosps your bra well
because he was like lay on your and well
you didn't want me walking around
without a bra I actually appreciated
that
because we were doing like exercises and
stuff imagine I have to do exercises
without a bra yeah
but then there was a Porsche where I had
to put this like thing on my back and so
I laid on my stomach and he was like he
just unhooked my bra like it wasn't
weird like I'm telling you
it's much too much the intricacies of
physical therapy I know but I really do
feel like slowly I'm making strides I
did my exercises last night I'm just
really looking forward to putting this
behind me I'm looking forward to that
too turdy
we want you know a happy
healthy healthy fit turdy that's really
all I want too so I'm I'm doing
everything I can to nip this problem in
the bud well I have to commend you on
you taking action thank you and I'm
being I'm really trying to be like a
good student yeah I love that for you I
have done my exercises every day since
the last session which was only on
Friday but still he's gonna be so
impressed with your I know with your
commitment with my progress yeah are you
doing it for that reason to impress no
I'm doing it because my back [__]
hurts and it's like what's the point of
going to physical therapy every single
week if I'm not gonna like actually do
it then it's just like a waste of
everyone's time and money
doing it to impress
no I'm really like I'm gonna I'm gonna
have the strongest back this side
of the East River you're never gonna see
it back so strong when I'm done can't
wait
I can't wait too how's belly belly is
good
belly is good period yeah all's
good why quiet here I finished some book
I just started the redheads book wait
really quickly back to Billy
what fruit is belly today
I better not say really yeah it's
private
[Laughter]
are you being seriously gonna tell us
again no I'm not gonna tell you oh my
God not her gate keeping the fruit yeah
I'm gatekeeping the fruit okay girl boss
gate keep repeat I love that for me yeah
that's me period
are you a gatekeeper of like if you find
something fabulous are you gonna share
it with like you know people or are you
gonna gatekeep it people like being like
my followers and such and the listeners
yeah yeah I feel like I share yeah yeah
yeah like if you found like a secret
hack to life like you're gonna keep it
for yourself you're gonna share I'm
gonna share that's like kind of what we
do here we just like I'm not a
gatekeeper no I guess I'm not
your heart is too big
oh that's so beautiful it is you're like
you're like the lion
in The Wizard of Wizard of Oz yeah his
heart was too big
is that what it is he's a coward
what's the lion and then there's one who
doesn't have a brain
Jackie there's someone whose heart was
too big
I don't think that's in The Wizard of Oz
no okay maybe not but like there was
like a kids movie where it's like his
heart grows yeah yeah yeah anybody know
what I'm talking about I do
and I feel like is it the Grinch like
his heart grew by the end it's the
Grinch very similar very similar but
better
but better the Grinch is so good and I
hope they never remake it they just did
but yeah
they did a cartoon version
and then they did the Matthew Morrison
version no those don't count I mean like
because like you know movies like that
get remade every you know Beauty and the
Beast gets they always get like a
facelift but there will never be a
better Grinch than Jim Carrey and they
should just leave it at that I agree I
think they will for a while at least you
know for the next decade yeah who do you
think is like the next Grinch you think
he's born yet
I think it's
who's like a crazy comedian who does
like crazy voices but who's young who's
young great actor actor yeah
doesn't exist yet it's honestly like
Joaquin Phoenix
no he probably was up for the role with
Jim Carrey yeah because they're like
similar ages and they have like similar
crazy faces remember when Jim Carrey was
dating Ariana Grande never forget I
think about that more often than I
should it was never like fully confirmed
that they were dating but they were like
being weird and hanging out and like
that was weird that was enough for me I
believed it either believe or I
disbelieved like you give me two people
in the I'll either believe that they're
together or not I'm I'm not off I'm not
usually right about what I believe yeah
about celebrity relationships like I
think it's business when it's romantic I
think it's romantic when it's business
and
that's just the vibe I got dating so
you're a doubter
non-believer
once were her
dreamers only when it comes to Selena
right now um I don't know why it's just
giving not believing I'm just not
believing some of these things that are
coming out about like the Romantic
Endeavors of Selena
as in Zayn and Drew tagger yes that's
what you're referring to that's what I'm
referring to
eating it all up you know living in
Fairyland yeah that's also fun and
sometimes you just have to jump right in
and then you never know you get a couple
like Avril and Tyga I know it's just
like in this age of information we're
living in we are constantly bombarded
there are so many stories we talk about
here that were never true that we never
get like follow-ups on it's just like
it's non-stop with like Anonymous gossip
and like you know people everywhere
having a cell phone taking pictures like
we are but constantly bombarded with
information that like never turns out to
be true but like we spend so much time
and brain power like talking about you
know the possibility of it being true
yeah and so many things like that we
were never meant to know like I feel
like now if somebody's go on one date
like we'll hear about it whereas emrada
and Harry yeah but back in the day you
wouldn't have and then you know 20 years
later that person goes and Watch What
Happens Live and they're like oh yeah I
went on a date with so and so one time
and it's just a fun fact but you didn't
get invested in it because now it's just
in the past but now we get invested in
all of these small things so and so
we're spotted at dinner and it's like
what does it mean like the weekend in
Angelina Jolie
what does it mean
it meant nothing
did it
nothing ever came of it I know and she
was just like spotted on the three-hour
lunch date with a billionaire yeah I saw
that too but I don't know lunch date
it's not giving romance it's not sexy no
but Nobu Malibu where they had lunch is
a very sexy venue but Nobu Malibu is so
business and so pleasure it could go
either way but like where the where
Angelina and the weekend had dinner is
actually a romantic spot yeah where is
it Giorgio Baldi yeah and you know yeah
when I went to Georgia about do you know
who I saw having dinner together
by the way I didn't know you've been to
Giorgio Baldi I have you wouldn't expect
that from me I've actually been there a
couple times what yeah like every time I
go to LA with Zach we go look at you I
know I'm really famous and fancy
literally but you know who I saw who was
there dining whining and dining being
romantic as hell
give me a clue uh they're no longer
together they were together for much
longer than people expected young
Hollywood we came to ship towards the
end they love to walk their dog
Sean Mendes and Camila Cabello ding ding
ding that last clue gave it to me yeah I
saw them like and they were extremely
into each other yeah
yeah I believe that relationship at
first I didn't yeah no and me I think I
already believed it by the time I saw
them together but it was like if I
hadn't believed I would have been a
Believer you know this is actually a
good time to bring up a story I actually
meant to to tell you about for a story
today but it's fine because I'm bringing
it up now okay did you see that Nick
file had Rachel Bilson on his podcast
and they both admitted to like
pretending to be in a relationship
because they wanted attention yes
I was like really shook by that
yeah but I was really grateful for the
Insight
um it definitely made me look at racial
bills indifferently because you know
Nick vial is a reality star he's an
influencer podcaster like these are
things people at at that level ourselves
included you know gimmicks we must rely
on it's the game we play like I don't
think that Nick vial is necessarily
above doing things like that and I don't
think he would disagree but Rachel
Bilson like should be yeah well they
were like getting into a podcast
together
right and then they wanted Buzz for
their podcast together so they said that
they were dating or like allowed people
to say that they were dating it was just
it was bizarre for Rachel Bilson to
admit that yeah
it's bizarre for her to do it it's
actually cool for her to admit it yes I
I like that yeah especially now that
she's a podcaster so like honesty is
your currency yeah it's just for me what
I think about
um like people that she came up with
people that she's dated like Adam Brody
Leighton Meester per se like they're all
really on the same level like they would
never do that you know yeah but why not
why can't she Branch out
in the Box
I'm putting her on a pedestal not on in
a box like I just I think highly of her
you're putting her on a box on a really
like high Shelf
or on a pedestal like I said yeah no I
think highly of her too but I think her
brand is changing she's you know more of
a personality now and like these are
just fun things that you share and and
Trust I'm sure those a-listers that
you've referenced have I have done
something similar yeah yeah yeah they're
just not man enough to admit it no no
because then it's like people are gonna
doubt everything you do you know yeah
but not if you're honest about it once
um
I don't know we'd have to see how hard
they went in trying to convince us like
I think it was a few Instagram comments
and probably some well-placed sources
but not like them yeah kissing on it
like actually
yeah yeah that's true that's true yeah
just say messed with us we were messed
with turdy Lou we were messed with
we got missed and but that's actually
great what we were just saying we see so
many of these like items these couples
these rumors to be dating and they never
go anywhere and it's like at least we
button that one up
yeah but we got played for a fool what
about January Jones though
January Jones Nick vial question I feel
like we've asked him about it
did we yeah like either when we were on
his show or vice versa or offline like I
feel like
we definitely brought that up what did
he say
I don't remember
must have not been like that juicy
because we would have remembered
something like crazy yeah I think the
what I'm remembering and I might be it's
just a Vibe was like he was just a
shocked as we were got it got it got it
yeah okay
and it feels like so you know
the ladies love him well he's a taken
man now yeah that's true he's engaged oh
you know the bachelor finale was on last
night no who won I have no idea but like
isn't that crazy that it was on yeah
that is crazy in all my stories
searching this morning I didn't even see
anything you're lying I saw uh what kind
of chapstick Zach shell crosswares to
keep his lips kissable
these Publishers are getting so out of
control with their and you know they
make like affiliate money when they like
link to the chapstick.com it's so
pathetic it really is like that's
journalism yeah
I can't I won't you're not curious what
it what it was actually what was it I
think it was Burt's Bees
the worst chapstick on the planet I know
it doesn't move
it's it's like putting cement on your
lips yeah it's just a plastic to wrap
around what do you think is the best
chapstick obviously Aquaphor Aquaphor
for me I I just switched to something
like that's a little cleaner than
Aquaphor wow it's called waxeline
and I just keep a tub by my bed and it's
it's good
but I mean like traditional chapstick
like in a tube lip balm I like
ballistics chapstick ballistics is good
because it's medicinal yeah but it's a
little too small I was constantly going
through the packets
Carmex she's good CarMax is intense no
sugar the nostril hair is on and it's
like everything you eat tastes like
Carmex everything you drink tastes like
Carmex it's like
it's a contagious yeah the smell yeah
EOS some of the worst some of the worst
Rosebud Salve chef's kiss Rosebud
Salvage delicious but I want to know who
is in charge of like distribution and
marketing for Eos because they managed
to get like one of the worst products of
all time into into the hands of Millions
every literally every store no matter
what you go to like if they don't sell
like a Cosmetics store like you guys
have Chapstick they carry an EOS like
they're at a cigar store like it is
crazy it's so true that they have great
marketing I also remember they had good
PR they were in Miley's music video for
We Can't Stop they were everywhere and
they also had like the little balls and
everyone was like oh a ball like it's
horrible chapstick like when some if I'm
ever with people and they're like I'm
like does someone have Chapstick and
they have EOS I'm like does someone have
Chapstick somebody has EOS yeah I feel
like that's something I've experienced a
lot like people offering me EOS and it's
like first of all that's disgusting it's
a very personal thing yes it is it's not
shareable yeah no it's not and of all
the Chapsticks in the world why is that
the one that you have chosen because
they sell it at every store they
probably had no choice but to buy the
EOS no but they also sell usually like a
couple sticks yeah like by the register
they always have the Chapstick brand
which are pretty good I love a stick I
really do yeah
um nivea's is not great isn't it just
moisturizer yeah no they make a
ChapStick and it's like it's like looks
good and it feels good when you put it
on and then 30 seconds later you're like
have I died and gone to the desert like
it's horrible yeah yeah there's a lot of
that it's really hard but you know those
kind of Beauty Brands who make like
elevated lip balms those are pretty good
like summer Fridays is really good yep
Covey just came out with a lip oil
I think yeah the cubby one is very good
um
what was I gonna say oh glossier makes
like a decent one there's a few and
croissant I could literally write a
dissertation on ChapStick like I feel
like what's your favorite one you know
you're gatekeeping yours Aquaphor okay
so then is there a need for these other
ones
no no but you never know you're in a
bind you have to run into a pharmacy and
they don't have Aquaphor well they have
forever but you know what I mean yeah
yeah but in a desperate situation I'll
take what I can get even Burt's Bees
right that's how we came to this topic
of conversation yeah so the bachelor was
on last night I hope for those of you
watch that you got the outcome that you
so desired yeah and
that they live happily together forever
forever and ever who's the last couple
that's like the most recent couple
that's still together
Rachel and Brian
no
Ari and Lauren
they were way before Rachel and no
they're not
they're not no
I don't think sure I don't know let me
look it up hang on no I'm pretty sure it
went from Nick to Rachel a member they
wanted Peter Krause but instead we got
Ari
and Lauren
I'm right
I already did the math okay because I
couldn't find what I was looking for
anyway and then after REO Becca's not
together
yeah after Becca we had Colton's not
together right after Colton we had
to you Sean Claire no
Hannah around not together together
oh Peter but Peter's like kind of with
Kelly Flanagan yeah they're together but
they weren't even close to right
together from the show even fourth but I
guess that's what we could say Peter and
Kelly
yeah tentatively because of
the caveat that she didn't win but she
was on the show that's how they met
actually you know they met at that you
know the Westlake Four Seasons or
whatever you're right
uh like that was for me and my
relationship with the franchise that
Peter uh what's his last name pilot was
my last straw like that was my nail in
the coffin that was my 13th reason like
that the way I felt so as a you like as
a viewer so
used like I can't explain how my time
was so wasted
on this like one of the probably one of
the worst bachelors in history and I
love Kelly Flanagan this is nothing
against her yeah but he had good girls
it's all about the crop he had amazing
girls Hannah and Maddie Prue Kelsey
Victoria Victoria
2.0 yeah
he did have good girls and then from
there we had Claire and Tasha Tisha
and then Madame Rachel Madden Rachel
Madden Rachel yeah Madam Rachel yeah but
they like broke up I know but she's
still the winner like yeah yeah she's
the winner no you're right you're right
so that is the most recent couple uh we
could keep going but we don't know who
won so crazy how like they got back
together after that you know yeah but
they're so in love they've been together
for so long and they're not even engaged
like they're just being like normal and
dating and living life and seems like
they enjoy their life together
are they engaged no
that's crazy now
because they didn't get engaged on the
show they didn't get engaged on the show
did she did he propose before after the
final Rose that's such a great question
let me Google it I do not believe that
they are engaged I don't they're
definitely not engaged right now but did
they get engaged call off their
engagement and then get back together as
a couple
I think so
that's like wild
it's like a whole explainer
like I wish Google's would sometimes
just be like yes or no
yeah yes or no or anything are you
texting are you still texting [__]
yes or no also do you see Blac Chyna's
new face I did she looks really good I
literally can't discern from all of this
text if they're engaged if they were
ever engaged or not I believe that they
did get engaged I believe that they
didn't for some reason oh that just like
they chose each other but yes I saw that
Blac Chyna is dissolving her fillers she
looks beautiful yeah she was changing
her look I think she got some tattoos
removed she is off of only fans she has
I think like dedicated her body and soul
to Christ she got baptized Christ looks
good on her Christ looks good on her she
is on a path of virtue virtuousness this
is good for this is good for everyone
yeah I think it's um I think it's a good
path for her yeah
and she looks beautiful yeah she does
she's a beautiful face she's a beautiful
girl she is I like I forgot yeah because
there's a lot of distractions right
right
so well I feel like we should dive in
because we already spoke of like four
stories about you know four stories that
I didn't choose the bachelor Nick vile
Blac Chyna so here are the fast side
stories that I did choose for today
and today's episode is brought to you by
Caraway get a head start on spring
cleaning with Caraway their thoughtfully
designed sets and complimentary storage
makes staying and getting organized
easier than ever you can now save 10 off
the full speed of Caraway products from
their internet famous cookware to their
newly launched food storage set
caraway's high quality ceramic coated
kitchenware is free of PTFE like Teflon
it's free of lead cadmium and other
toxic chemicals caraway's kitchenware
comes in a variety of chic Shades and
all sets include complementary easy
access storage solutions they're a
naturally slick surface means minimal
oil or butter for slide off the pan eggs
and easy cleaning I'd like to share an
anecdote about you know Caraway
yesterday
um just helping my marriage because Ben
went into the kitchen and he's like I'm
gonna make a sandwich I'm like okay he's
taking a long time and I wanted to get
the oil treats where they go in I'm like
what is going on and there's like dishes
I'm like why is there a pan you made a
sandwich and he's like oh I wanted to
toast the bread
I'm like so use the toaster no he used
the pan and honestly it was Caraway and
it really was so easy to clean like I
didn't have to throw it in the
dishwasher because it was just a piece
of bread so you know what all was
forgiven because he used the Caraway pan
yes and you actually shouldn't throw it
in the dishwasher anyway so that's best
for you yeah
um so again it's non-toxic easy cooking
and it's super well loved over 40 000
people including us have raved about
their Caraway kitchen visit
carawayhome.com toast10 to take
advantage of this limited time offer of
10 off your next purchase that deal is
exclusive for our listeners so visit
carawayhome.com toast10 or use code
toast10
at checkout Caraway non-toxic cookware
made Modern today's episode is also
brought to you by Starbucks ready to
drink life moves fast Starbucks ready to
drink coffee delivers an uplifting boost
that helps you tune into the moments
that matter wherever you are so with
Starbucks coffee but it's conveniently
packaged for life on the go it includes
a variety of beverages they have a
bottled Frappuccino which is like a
chilled coffee drink for a pop of flavor
um they also have the Bold smooth Taste
of the Nitro cold brew which I love the
bottled Frappuccino chilled coffee drink
is inspired by the Starbucks cafe
favorites and it comes in four delicious
flavors like mocha vanilla caramel and
coffee you can enjoy every moment with
Starbucks ready to drink coffee we keep
them here at the studio we have a ton of
the Starbucks ready to drink beverages
they're so good Ben actually recorded in
here last night and needed just like a
boost you know a nice flavorful boost
and he was really impressed with the not
me making everything about Ben today I'm
obsessed but he was he was impressed
with our array of products to offer him
here while he recorded his podcast
um
so if you uh want to shop the full
lineup you can shop it online or in
store it's wherever you buy groceries
you'll be able to find Starbucks coffee
ready for right now shop the full lineup
online or in store wherever you buy
groceries and that's Starbucks ready to
drink coffee they are delivering an
uplifting boost that helps you tune into
the moments that matter wherever you are
and it's so great like at your office by
your desk wherever you are just you know
churning out things throughout the day
keep a Starbucks beverage you know you
never know when you need it
so true turdy so true turdy are you
ready for our first story yes Taylor
Swift stole the show last night at the
iHeartRadio Music Awards Taylor took
home top honors during I heart's big
awards show and while her acceptance
speeches were touching it was her
wardrobe that really Drew eyes she
looked beautiful she won song of the
year and the innovator award Monday
night and in both instances she
delivered some powerful remarks about
what it takes to stand out and succeed
in the music Biz noting that the formula
of a hit song isn't cut and dry of
course she was talking about her fan
favorite track anti-hero which one song
of the year she picked out certain
lyrics like narcissism and altruism as
examples so not everything has to be so
catchy and cookie cutter arguing that
artists can be real with their art she
sparkled in a hooded number who made it
I don't know
she looks beautiful like I love so
different for her it was getting
reputation you know everyone thinks it's
like a clue I just think she looked good
like I'm not gonna read into it yeah
like it does have a reputation vibe to
it but I almost think that was
accidental because it is also kind of
midnight see the color yes that's true
and maybe it's photographing differently
than like how it was in person no I
think just the fact that there's a hood
makes it reputation because you know
she's like
Darkness yeah but
the color the Sparkles the hairstyle
like it's still in line with midnight so
I think it was just like
coincidental you know something that
perplexes me about my queen is you know
at the level that she's at she is
constantly showing up to like
moronic fake award shows that like she's
so much better than she's like always
going to like Billboard Music Awards
American Music Awards and I know it's
because those are like the fan voted
events and she's really you know wants
to show up for her fans but it's like
Beyonce would never go to the I Heart
Radio awards you know it's like
fraudulent yeah I think that there's a
part of her brand where it's like we
need a couple controlled events where we
can you know
know that we're gonna win and be in a
friendly environment like I think
obviously the Grammys is not that you
don't know if you're going to win and
there are so many other big stars like I
think this is just an easy night out for
Taylor where she's able to like do a red
carpet drop Clues talk to their fans
right yeah it works out with her tour uh
it's like an easy nice way for people to
see her
no I just like I think I always think
it's weird when I see her at these
events and she's like really the only
actual famous person there yeah I think
there's something about it that's
probably really comforting and
productive for whatever she's putting
forth no and I also think you know she
one of her goals is to be like one of
the most decorated
female artists of our time and in order
to be decorated you have to show up to
these things but does this count as
decoration it does it does it counts as
an award like it does okay is is there
like a list of awards that count are
there any awards that really don't count
no that's a such a good point because if
there was I would think it was this
right
I don't know I'm just always like when
she went to like the Teen Choice Awards
and like she gave this like big speech
and it was like her night why is she
always like slumming out at these events
I I really I would love it if anybody
has any like theories like because I
think it's because
she wants to be highly decorated and
that's that's my theory like I would
just she's so much better than this
I think it's I don't think it's about
the decorations because I don't think
that those really count towards anything
meaningful especially when you're
winning Grammys right you're up for
Oscars like I don't think they're in the
same category I really I think it's
um
I think it's like PR I do and it's a
good PR it's always good like you know
that you're gonna win it's flattering
it's low pressure maybe it's just
because I look at everything with such a
critical eye but like I don't really see
like when I see clips of like they're
like song of the year goes to and the
only famous person in the room is Taylor
Swift Andy hero and she's like ah like
to me like I don't even think that's a
good look honestly no I know but you
also have to remember like Taylor is
still Taylor you know and like at her
Court like she wants just like love and
acceptance I know and to win these
things and she can't help herself but be
like oh like she there's she that's the
only reaction that she knows it's like
when when she goes to these events
and we always say like award shows like
this have one token like actually a
famous person and then they get all the
awards it's like whoever shows up right
um and so I feel that way with anyone
this is not just Taylor yes it just it
feels like they're playing a part it's
like a the whole night is a charade yeah
but the industry like that's what it
takes in the industry like like I think
she is so authentic with her fans and
she really as much as she can is very
like DTC but there is all this [__]
that you have to do something radio and
she like in order to get played on the
radio this is iHeartRadio yeah yeah like
it's just industry bow [__] that and I
feel like when a lot of people get to
that level they they stop playing the
game like they're they don't have to do
that anymore but like she doesn't and
that's why to me it feels out of place
yeah and they have a lot of like disdain
for all of that because I think some of
it is it's not tired and it's political
and you know it's not always like the
cream Rising it's just people making
choices true but I think this stuff is
still important to her and so and she
does she would never do something that
like she is vehemently again but like
getting played on the radio and all of
that like yeah you care yeah yeah yeah
no it's just it always feels weird to me
yeah anyway she looked great and she's
really just it's good it's good few
weeks to be Taylor no she's in like a
really um fantastic for lack of a better
word era it's true like she's killing it
are you ready for our next story yeah
because this was an element of yes a
straight a story that we forgot to talk
about but more news is coming out
from page six saying that emrata is
apparently begging for Olivia Wilde's
forgiveness after Harry Styles PDA
so a source tells page six that emirata
is begging for Olivia Wilde's
forgiveness forgiveness after video of
the model making out with her ex Harry
Styles went viral over the weekend Daily
Mail published video of them making out
in Tokyo a sourceful page six that
Olivia and Emily are friends and that
Emily is now begging for her forgiveness
this is a betrayal says thesaurus just
weeks ago Olivia Wilde and rata were
photographed hanging out together at the
2023 Vanity Fair Oscars bash last June
Olivia and emrado were seated next to
each other in the VIP section at Harry
Styles concert in Paris where they were
spotted Palling around and dancing
together emrata also came to Olivia's
defense when she faced criticism about
uh promoting her movie don't worry
darling
saying that she felt protective of wild
so I do think based on these things
there is an established friendship
between these two yeah and
that would mean amaretta making out with
Harry is no bueno there also was a rumor
that we forgot to talk about yesterday
from
that M that Olivia Wilde and Harry
Styles when they were together had a
threesome with emrata allegedly from
dumwa then these photos of them dancing
at his concert in Paris
yeah I guess that would have been the
time in the place for a menage à trois I
don't know if I necessarily believe that
um but the the whole other part of this
where you know Olivia and emrata are
friends which by the way makes so much
sense like they're literally the same
like everything I always say I feel like
I said the same thing about Imran that I
said about Olivia Wilde like that brand
of like you know wearing a feminist
t-shirt like well also like hating women
like I like to me they're the same and
so I I actually can see them being
really good friends I feel like they
probably have like really similar values
and opinions on stuff
um
and the other thing to follow up from
yesterday is that Harry and Olivia nope
Harry and emrada were both at an event I
think for like Michael Kors or something
they
we're there for different reasons he
didn't fly her out we didn't fly her out
but like they were there at the same
event that's really helpful so to me if
I'm looking at this on a on a board you
know like an investigator here's what I
think I think Olivia and emrata are
friends I think they had a threesome
with Harry when Olivia was together I
think it was a great time was had by all
I think fast forward
six months later eight months later
they're broken up
Harry and M run into each other at this
event it's like they've already been
intimate we had a good time and always
in a threesome there's a weird thing
that happens of course and by the way
let's say they did have a threesome
Olivia Wilde like how dumb are you
you're gonna bring the hot and like
Olivia Wilde is a beautiful woman but
you're gonna bring the hottest young
thing on the planet into the bedroom
with your younger boyfriend like are you
uh okay
because that's a dumb thing to do that's
why I don't even believe it because I
don't even think Olivia Wilde would be
so stupid no I think that she would I
don't think she sees women as
threatening I think she wouldn't like
that's very uh
you know non-feminist thing to say like
don't bring the younger hotter girl
around I'm sorry uh I'm a feminist no no
I know
but it's just like I could just see her
being like
yeah love is you know for everyone yeah
and that you wouldn't exclude one woman
just because of the way she looks and
that you know what I mean but like I
know but you know what at the end of the
day like dating relationships it's all a
game and you have to do anything to keep
your man especially when your man is the
hottest man on the planet but that's not
how she sees things because you see
things differently no I see things in
reality no I see things the way that you
I see things the way that you see things
here I'm just trying to like get into
her mindset because I don't think she
like thinks that way you gotta keep your
man keep him away from other women
because like that's just not the Vibes
forth well you do you do
I mean that would be like me saying
hey Giselle
want to [__] me and my husband like how
dumb am I yeah like we get in there
Ben's not looking at me
yeah well who knows what happened in the
alleged threesome but clearly it went
well because a little too well Harry and
M were happy to see each other in Tokyo
right so now like thinking if they had a
threesome they're making out is just
nothing yeah it's like they've been
there done that and
I'm sure Olivia if they do have a decent
friendship I'm sure Olivia's pissed at
her like you were just making out with
my ex but she also has no one to blame
of herself or bring them together
you invited her into the bedroom like
now you're mad they kissed in Tokyo when
you asked for a lot of that yeah
before you let them [__]
yeah but this definitely throws a wrench
into
emrata and Harry like dating in the
future no there it's not they're not
gonna date like because I'm telling you
we were never meant to know this Olivia
Wilde was never meant to find out that
they smooched in Tokyo they're on the
other side of the world they're young
and single okay so they've kissed after
they had a threesome that's nothing we
were not meant to know this was
disaster I I actually think emrada like
really is
um like a girls girl
like I think that she is okay and I
think that like even if Harry wanted to
date like I think she's focused on
getting back in the good graces of
Olivia Wilde honestly
I think she doesn't care about Harry
enough to ruin her friendship with
Olivia Wilde but I think that if it were
a guy that she was all in for
um
so long so long farewell I'll need to
say not you I do I do to you any and you
you and you that's how the kids say it
in the movie Austrian Austrian campers
how are you
um so yeah these two are definitely not
like I do believe this is probably the
last we'll see of them and it was
supposed to be we were never supposed to
see them and like what little sneaky
sneaky phone who did that no not even
I'm sorry not the phone like thankful
for the phone whoever like was at that
party and knew that we needed to see
this but the two of them sneaky because
like yeah imagine this happened like we
never knew about it but it's like just
knowing the history we're not supposed
to know like that's really a bad look
for emirata because I think she is a
girls girl and a girls girl doesn't do
that no
right
yeah no right are you ready for our next
story
yeah
because it's some sad relationship news
that I do feel relates to the show
okay but it doesn't in in the sense that
it doesn't relate to the show oh in that
sense okay
let me let me explain
Backstreet Boys aging it does it does
Backstreet Boys AJ McLean and his wife
Rochelle separate temporarily to build a
stronger future now I'm going to give
you the information and then we'll talk
about how it might find my pertinent
information how it may or may not relate
to the show
AJ McLean and his wife Rochelle are
taking some time apart the Backstreet
Boys singer who's 45 and his wife who's
41 that might become important
information later on are separating
after 11 years of marriage but plan to
reunite in the future they claim
a statement was put forth marriage is
hard but worth it we have mutually
decided to separate temporarily to work
on ourselves and our marriage with the
hope of building a stronger future the
plan is to come back together and
continue to nurture our love for one
another and our family we ask for
respect and privacy at this time
quote separation is hard enough without
the commentary oof we're about to
comment
please be kind and please be kind and
remember there are children involved
turdy Lou
turdy Lou okay [__] oh sorry there are
children involved end quote turdy Lou
oh now to you turdy Lou no no no no no
it was it was definitely directed at you
but I didn't want you to think it was
part of AJ's statement
oh I know that is what my like immediate
thought here's what I got tagged in this
so many times yesterday because if you
listen to the toast every day you know
that a few weeks ago someone wrote into
Deer toasters talking about how a former
popular boy band member who they
listened to a lot growing up came to
their college for a tour I'm trying to
find it let me get the um get the
details came to a college for a tour and
kind of like was putting the moves on
her and then texting and appropriate and
whatnot and wanting to come backstage
and all that jazz and it turned out that
he is married and he has three kids so
the toaster was asking like what do I do
should I message the wife like what what
do I do so we gave our best advice but
then we also tried to speculate about
who it was and our best guess was that
it was Nick Carter from the Backstreet
Boys because he's married and has three
kids however
and so now people think maybe it was AJ
McLean he's married he has three kids
he's a boy bander they're on tour Etc
however the ages and the timelines
actually do not add up for it to be
Backstreet Boys because this girl who
wrote in I think she is 20 which would
mean that you have to remember we're
more than 20 a lot more than 20. she
would not even have been alive really or
maybe she'd been like screaming in the
crib for when the Backstreet Boys
had their Peak people were guessing a
lot of other bands that are not like
from the Backstreet Boys in sync 90s era
that are more contemporary like uh I
forgot what they were dming and stuff
I'll have what episode was it
let me go to the episode because the
comments give good band recommendations
and I enough to convince me that it
wasn't the back shot I thought I a lot
of people agreed with me when they said
it was Big Time Rush yes they did
and I thought that was a good call
I thought that was a good call too like
I really don't think it was someone from
the Backstreet Boys I think this is just
coincidence I think it is too
um
but you know
you can't help but speculate
yeah because but I feel like I mean the
statement gives nothing
yeah the statement gives nothing and
like why do you have to separate to work
on your marriage if like something
didn't happen but also like
I don't know I I mean I want to respect
their privacy we met AJ McLean I'm the
CMA start carpet and he was so nice a
doll a dog it was so nice turdy so okay
wait I think they're just going through
something okay this was her submission I
found it finally
growing up I always had this video what
day did we do it
March oh I don't know when did you don't
know no okay growing up I always had a
favorite band their sixth concert I went
to was near my University when I went to
the concert I had the opportunity to
meet them one of the members talked to
me a lot and we kind of hit it off and
he uh asked to follow me on Instagram
and then proceeded to DM me saying it
was nice to meet me the next morning I
looked at his Instagram and to my
surprise I saw in his profile that he
was married with three kids around a
year later he dm'd me and told me that
he was gonna be playing a concert near
me again he was just messaging me and
practically begging me to come backstage
before the concert I went to the concert
and talked to him it was nice and chatty
but nothing I wouldn't have said if his
wife was there after the concert I told
him my friends uh I told my friends that
were at the concert with me we're headed
home he responded with if I came back
with you what's in it for me I'm sure
he's doing this with other girls uh he
meets during tour do I DM the wife yada
yada he's trying to hook up with girls
10 plus year younger than him
she's 20. he's 45. yeah it's not him
it's not him
so we must respect their privacy at this
time no but the only real thing is that
they had three kids they both have three
kids and that's not like a a lot of
people have three kids and there were a
lot of people in the comments who are
offering other possibilities yeah I
definitely still feel confident in my
big time rush because they're a little
bit younger they're Backstreet Boys yeah
there were other bands too that I didn't
know but apparently they do like college
tours Backstreet Boys don't do go to
colleges not yet not for a while like
they maybe did that in the beginning of
their career but I think Big Time Rush
does so I think everyone here is clear I
think so too and now we can just talk
about how sad it is at AJ McLean and his
wife are separating yes but I'm glad to
hear that they're separating with the
intention of getting back together like
I hope that that's true and that they
can work through whatever rough patch
they found themselves in for the
children for the children of course yeah
agreed so uh
excuse me
they only have two kids
oh why did everyone send this to me
changes everything yeah
so it's definitely not him sorry to even
mention it literally sorry to smear
libel and defame AJ McLean this morning
not cool of us but we cleared his name
name equals cleared Clarita
Clarita
are you ready for our next story if it's
the next story that's brought to you by
Skylight frames it is turdy Lou Who you
know JAX on those long lonely nights I
really miss you because you're not here
anymore and you know there's so many
things I want to share with you
day-to-day life things that just
photos I want to show you of Theo I love
your outfits but I have finally found
something that makes it easy to help me
and my loved ones stay connected the
Skylight frame ever miss your loved ones
when you aren't together do they miss
you hopefully well here's a gift that
brings you all together no matter how
far apart you live the Skylight frame
Skylight frame is a touch screen photo
frame that your whole family can email
photos to and they'll appear in seconds
you get to share your favorite moments
with the people who matter most to you
it's a great gift for parents
grandparents someone with a birthday
coming up someone who just had a baby or
even just for yourself anyone can send
photos to the frame in just seconds via
email or via their app it's a great way
to keep in touch with friends and family
it's super simple to use the setup takes
less than 60 seconds and even the least
tech savvy person can use it it looks
like a real photo that adds a beautiful
touch to your home it holds thousands of
photos that continuously rotate and
bring daily Joy the Skylight frame has a
gorgeous touch screen it comes in two
sizes the original 10 inch and a new
15-inch Gallery frame you can swipe
through photos with your finger even tap
it to heart the photo and thank the
person who sent it so I get asked about
like the what's the digital photo frame
company that sponsors the toast all the
time it is Skylight frames they have 100
satisfaction guarantee so if you don't
love your Skylight they will issue you a
full refund time goes fast staying in
touch with those we love is more
important than ever and now the Skylight
frame makes it easy and fun as a special
offer for our listeners get 15 off your
purchase of a skylight frame when you go
to skylightframe.com toast that's 15 off
your purchase of a skylight frame when
you go to Skylight frame.com toast
s-k-y-l-i-g-h-t-f-r-a-m-e.com slash
toast thank you Claudia you're welcome
Jackie our next story a little TV news
White Lotus season three some Deets are
emerging one DEET it will be set in
Thailand the White Lotus is heading to
Thailand multiple sources close to the
production tell variety as the first two
seasons of Mike whites the White Lotus
were shot at Four Seasons resorts in
Hawaii and Italy respectively it's
possible that season three will take
place at one of the luxury hotels for
properties in Thailand that does make
sense HBO has to clean it again so the
uh White Lotus Hawaii and Italy were
both shot at Four Seasons properties oh
Four Seasons yeah but the hotel is
called the White Lotus
um so there are four four seasons in
Thailand
is Bali in Thailand
yes but there is not a Four Seasons
there
no but probably a country
right oh Indonesia Indonesia is Bali
sorry I got my because like the nicest
hotel in the world like the one they say
is like the nicest is in Bali but I got
confused Bali is in Indonesia
mom geography Queen totally what's that
it's a Four Seasons no it's not a Four
Seasons but like it if they were going
to Bali which I just got confused I
imagine they would try and shoot it what
is great like widely renowned is like
the nicest hotel in in the world is that
where Rach was
who's rage Rach parcel she was just on a
and she was just in the Maldives oh oh
oh no it's called um
I'll Google it
it's like
Bibby it's like a it's a four-letter
word that starts with B
okay
17 best hotels in Hawaii maybe they're
in the alphabetical order
nihi n-i-h-i that's the one yeah it's
like I think it's regarded as like one
of the nicest hotels on the globe you
should go a hundred percent
but I feel like I mean of course they
need a gorgeous hotel and they will have
a gorgeous hotel but it's like there's
so many gorgeous hotels they don't need
to go to like the nicest one in the
globe because it's about like the story
so that's exciting I think that would be
a great location and then also rumored
about season three rumored casting news
extremely illegitimate they were just
spotted having dinner uh Mike White and
Danny DeVito
so I am actually really excited about
the potential of Danny DeVito because
now that we don't have Jennifer Coolidge
the show really requires that kind of
like you know really um
different out of the box sort of
character that Jennifer Coolidge played
and that Danny DeVito could definitely
play I do have to say I'm like
definitely like getting over White Lotus
like I think with each season there's
more Intrigue and it see it feels like
it's gotten worse like there was so much
Intrigue this season and like I get it
but like was it good
that's how it goes with the first season
two it was like season one was good
especially because we didn't know what
the show was about yeah just like
strapped in for whatever Journey we were
going on and then there was so much
pressure that like I feel like no matter
what season two was gonna fall flat but
it didn't people loved it and people say
season two is better than season one not
you but other people other people
[__] says that everyone
oh I don't agree
but I think it's a great concept for a
show they could do seasons forever and
they should do seasons forever
um
apparently like season one was more
focused on money and season two was more
focused on sex do you feel that way
sex they said there were two prostitutes
uh this uh White said in a clip the
first yes the first season kind of
highlighted money and then the second
season is sex I think the third season
would be maybe a satirical and funny
look at death in eastern religion and
spirituality it feels like it could be a
rich tapestry to do another round at
White Lotus I guess yeah no the first
one really was about money like Tanya
and the investment yeah and then the
other the second one isn't about money
like it's still no it was about rich
people but I guess like one of the major
themes was sex and like how it makes
people do crazy things oh
yeah it's kind of like a thin theme
yeah especially you didn't even really
realize that that's what they were up to
100 although you know grief and you know
Eastern
culture does sound like an interesting
yeah especially around death because
there's always a death
right right so the stakes keep getting
higher because the show keeps getting
bigger and winning more Awards and
what's so interesting about shows like
White Lotus that just like put into
perspective for me is like everyone
watches it everyone loves it and
everyone wants to be in it and I just
saw this clip because Kelty posted it
She interviewed Jennifer Aniston and
Adam Sandler and she was like asking
Jennifer Aniston if she would ever do
White Lotus she was like I would die
like I would love to and it's like these
are you know people at that level who
traditionally it's like you maybe start
in TV but like the goal was always
movies and doing TV was like kind of
like tacky you know it was like it was
definitely a step below and now with
these like miniseries that are so
popular and so well done and are really
just like very long movies at this point
it's crazy how like you know Silver
Screen
it's like not a thing anymore yeah but I
also think White Lotus holds a unique
position because it's like I don't know
that you want to be on a TV show for
eight seasons and like stuck doing
television unless it's Game of Thrones
but White Lotus it's like a one season
wonder and but it's not a mini series
because there could be Seasons that go
on forever kind of reminds me a True
Detective where it's like who's gonna be
the next detective and it's really
prestigious but you only have to do it
for like a year you get to do the
circuit and everything it seems like a
dream for an actor yeah I guess it's
like a mini series kind of even though
it's like a seasonal show I don't know
what the word is for a series that has a
lot of Seasons but every season is cool
so fresh
right is tabula rasa tabularast except
for Jennifer Coolidge but I also think
that since Jennifer Coolidge won't be
carried over to season three they should
carry someone over from season two to
season three
I guess yeah yeah just to continue that
thread I think that's a nice thread like
who was even well I would love to see
Megan Fahey but yeah she's on to Ellen
Hildebrandt totally as previously
reported on the toast totally but I do
think Danny DeVito would be a great
casting because he he
he is similar to Jennifer Coolidge and
the fact that he's so beloved he's so
iconic haven't seen him in a while would
love to see him again and I imagine if
I'm Mike White and like seeing
how things played out for Jennifer
Coolidge and I'm sure it wasn't even his
attention to like give someone's career
the star Resurgence and just like to
choose people who are kind of
their star is fading and by the way like
it was and is an ensemble cast like
Jennifer Coolidge wasn't in the first
season more than anyone else yeah the
reason why you know her part was so
different but she just people love her
yeah yeah so I think
he will try and do that again and he
should do that again because I think
it's a wonderful thing to do
and the way that Mike White is Ned
schnably is not lost on me right and so
it just makes you wonder when Jack Black
will be in a season
oh my God Jack Black in White Lotus is
exactly what they need yeah
and Miranda Cosgrove we're getting the
band back together
and Joan Cusack
yeah
huh
what do you think Joan Cusack's up to I
could tell you just living I feel like
she's probably like semi-retired
uh I'll tell you she might I just can't
be working on some things right
post-production some things
I feel she's definitely not retired
I feel like she hasn't been like spotted
in a while I live for her like literally
would take a bullet she I guess hasn't
done something since 2020
but she's has something upcoming I think
it's a short
um
like I said semi-retired yeah well
I'm ready for a Joan comeback White
Lotus season three notice yeah are you
ready for our fifth and final story
which is a little more TV news yeah
because the trailer for The Kardashians
dropped yesterday oh and was it giving
us nothing or what it was probably
giving us nothing though it was trying
really hard with some key pull quotes So
Kim Kardashian breaks down sobbing and
the dramatic teaser for season three of
Kardashians on Hulu she looks toward the
ground while using both her hands to
cover her face and breathes heavily in
the second long clip her sister Chloe
attempts to comfort her sister by
rubbing the back of her head with her
hand the trailer teases that Kim will
talk about several of the challenges she
faced
since filming resumed less fall so she
says in a confessional at the end of the
teaser so let's talk about it it's
unclear exactly unclear what we shall be
talking about there are a couple things
that she could talk about
um I think there's a lot that she won't
talk about what do we think she needs to
talk about
Balenciaga Balenciaga
peed and her split which I actually
think she'll she'll share more I think
she'll share more about their split than
she shared about their relationship
because when you have a relationship
like you want to protect her and nurture
it and like not bringing outside forces
but now that it's like dead and gone
like it's good fodder for the show it's
good father for the show but also like
there's so much that she needs to open
up about and I feel like she won't open
up about like she was very tight-lipped
about Balenciaga she's not going to talk
about Kanye so she has to bleed out in
other things and something irrelevant
like a breakup from now what over a year
ago not a year but yeah I agree I think
she will talk about that I think she
will talk about Balenciaga I think she
kind of has to
well there's the line from the trailer
that makes me think maybe they do where
Kylie's like you know
we have so much power and we have such a
big voice is this what we want to use it
for I don't think it's about Balenciaga
that I think it's just about like her
like then doing a storyline about like
giving back that it's a really powerful
quote that she shared but I I don't
think it's like gonna be
um oh part of a larger movement or
something oh damn okay that's just like
how I saw it I think she will talk about
Balenciaga because like that is what
people want to hear from her about
she did part ways with them
I think she kind of has to because that
seems to be really the reason why the
family's in the funk yeah
so
why not
she won't talk about Kanye which I
respect I do me too and um
I think she'll talk about Pete I don't
know what else is going on with her that
she needs to talk about
yeah I don't know really like they've
been so low-key so and I know the show
is like delayed so like we're gonna see
stuff from probably last year but like
that just feels so irrelevant now and
then they haven't really done anything
in the last couple of months because
they've been in this funk I just don't
feel like it's the right time like
honestly I don't think we need a season
right now oh I feel ready I'm ready to
be
I'm open I'm open to what they have to
share and what they have to say like I
feel like we've all been in a funk a
Kardashian funk I am I want to get out
of it there at times in my life like my
favorite celebrities ever so I feel like
I'm more interested to watch this season
than I was even to watch last season
when like all things were good you know
right
that's fair yeah no it's more
interesting for sure and they are sort
of in this rut so it'll be interesting
to see what they think the issues are
what they need to speak about and what
they have to say like
I'm like are they gonna acknowledge the
rock you know the what the rep
no no it's not that obvious to people
who aren't you and I really yeah
oh I feel like it's like very obvious no
it's not like there's people writing
articles about it there's not like viral
threads on Twitter like it's just me and
you being like
and I'm sure other people feel that way
but they don't recognize that they feel
that way it's not like a a national
movement but they're in a rut oh I
totally thought it was no it's just us
doing our thing
uh I'd rather see you out there doing
that thing yeah but nothing that they
can't come back from but they're gonna
have to give
they're gonna have to like bleed out a
little yeah which should open up let's
be real like tell us what's going on
yeah I mean they do right I know but
like they kind of do like when it's like
so late and I know that's like just the
nature of the show and they want to save
it all for the show but like
so if you're gonna like bleed out and
tell me all about Pete now like I so
don't care you know no I'm I don't care
about Kim and Pete anymore like I've
moved on but I'm still open to hearing
what happened like that was really
so hot then so cold and like that to me
is
their personal life that they would be
sharing that like I want to hear about
yeah me too I wish we would have heard
about it like the day of but you gotta
give people this is not the day of not
the day of but like some sometimes like
so much has happened since then like
he's literally dated like two other
women right which is why which is why
she can talk about it now right right
you know because it feels dated there's
nothing for to protect he clearly is
moved on like
trash him
yeah literally you know we'll just have
to wait and see because honestly the
trailer gave little to nothing no the
trailer was really easy to see through
like they really thought they did
something they pulled some strong quotes
but like they're when you have watched
their show for so long you could see how
it's also like it could be about nothing
smoking mirrors yeah how are we using
our power and then they let go and they
do a day of service which would be
amazing right but not what it sounds
like not what it sounds like
totally it's easy to see through that's
a very very wet good way of saying it
but as stated I'm open
I'm open too like these are my girlies I
just need them to like you know bounce
back but you know what I'm not open to a
May 25th premiere date like that is in
two months and I want my content now
content with a K like I don't want to
wait two months on a measly trailer
yeah no I'm sure we'll get like drops of
stuff but yeah no it's unacceptable I
feel like you really shouldn't be
allowed to promote anything more than a
month a month Max it's better for them
too I agree because I'm open now I'm
interested but am I going to lose
interest I couldn't tell you right where
will we be May 25th you know
I don't know I'm hoping to be at the
Eris tour right is that Memorial Day
Weekend yeah yeah
you never know yeah
so those are the Fast Five thanks Jack
great stories today I enjoyed them
couldn't turn
that's so nice for you to say
um so that's our show
tis
yeah
hope you enjoyed it thank you so much
for listening to the Tesla Monday
Morning Show where we deliver the
fastest stories that you need to know
every Monday through Friday on YouTube
so if you're watching this on YouTube
please don't forget to subscribe and
this video a thumbs up we're also
available
videos
have a great day great see you tomorrow
for hump day love ya bye